you don't know me how do you know what
I'm about to say is something you can
trust
it's actually your responsibility to
make sure that your information is
authentic
this is where data literacy comes in it
can help you evaluate the reliability of
news sources make informed decisions
about your health and finances even
protect you from scams and
misinformation
and schooling data literacy can help you
understand and analyze complex
information in subjects like math and
science
and in the business World a culture of
data literacy means everyone in the
organization can make better data-driven
decisions plus it's a valuable skill
that can open up career opportunities in
fields like data science and market
research so don't just consume your data
at face value
to learn more about all things data head
on over to the data differentiator IBM
sky for data leaders and enthusiasts
alike we hope to see you there